today the Supreme Court heard oral
arguments in Friedreich's V California
Teachers Association public school
teacher Rebecca Friedreich's contends
that mandatory Union fees violate her
First Amendment right of free speech and
Association outside the court a rally
and counter rally revealed a polarized
public opinion of the case
my husband's a state representative and
in his first race for state rep he had a
huge campaign against him turned out to
be funded by the OEA and I realized that
my forced dues we're going to fund my
husband's that campaign against my
husband if you're in a worksite and
you're covered by a contract the union
contract you get the benefit of that
contract you get raises you've got the
health insurance you get the dental
vision and all the other benefits and
those things you know take energy and
time and cost money and it's to be able
to get and if we have less people
contributing to that everyone because
eventually we start to see those
benefits of road and this should not be
a race to the top we've got a great idea
it's gonna be compulsory anybody who
tells you they've got a great idea and
first thing is they make everybody dot
dot dot if it was such a good idea you
wouldn't have to make anybody nevermind
everyone do anything unions want to
fight with retirement pay for hours
everybody should share the cost of that
and if they don't then the freeloading
so to hear them user like a sense of
fear-mongering like if we don't take
agency fees everything is gonna crumble
and burn and the justices pushed back on
that are you telling me that even though
we have clear evidence that of other
states that don't take agency fees and
there's thriving they're surviving and
thriving are you here telling us that
the unions will collapse without agency
fees and they couldn't answer that
question our voices have been silenced
the unions forced me to fund collective
bargaining efforts that are harmful to
my students and that's offensive to our
voices were heard today so thank you